hello
hello may i come in yes you're welcome
thank you
how are you today natalia i'm fine
thank you and you thank you me too thank
you for agreeing to answer our 21
questions today
how did you travel to school today
natalia today is my
lucky day i came to school by bus and
it took me only two hours and how do you
usually travel to school
usually my route takes three hours
but i really like this time because i
read the books
and share my knowledge in
social networks facebook instagram
and sometimes i
create new crazy ideas for my students
what did you have for breakfast this
morning i had vegetarian breakfast today
what's your mindset when you enter the
school every day
hello my little house hello
how are you yes i talked to my school
would you please name one scene you love
about the area your school is in uh
i don't know maybe the cafeteria near my
school i like coffee very much
natalie who is your favorite movie star
tim schweiger
do you remember how he played in the
move
very spread well i haven't seen this
movie but i would love to
probably and what's your favorite scene
our own
or band oh freddie mercury
queen yes i like rogue music
and rogue bands who's your hero natalia
my sister yes my sister is my hero
would you please name one place you
would love to visit
ocean yes i dreamed to see the ocean
what was your favorite subject at school
when i was a child i liked literature
because i like to read very much
and what was your least favorite subject
at school
oh no geometry yes
i think i didn't understand to eat
because
i was afraid uh asking my teacher to
help
by the way what kind of student were you
at school
i was organized and motivated student at
school
what's your favorite food in the school
cafeteria
my school has no cafeteria but when
our school gets bigger i will have
delicious pancakes with berries
what time do you usually leave school
i try to keep work and life
balance but to be honest it doesn't work
in my case
what are your passions what are your
passions
and hobbies outside teaching i play
ukulele
sometimes my hobby therapy is
laziness yes and i
also like psychology
very much what's your proudest
achievement as a teacher
i'm proud of the smallest results
of my students when parents begin to
believe
in their children again if you could
write one motivational quote on your
blackboard
oops on your whiteboard what would it be
maybe maybe you can do it yes
you can
do it
what's the most important advice you
would give to your students
try try and try again
never give up why did you become a
teacher in italian
because somebody didn't take me to the
choreography class
i become a teacher because teacher
can do impossible possible it's a
magic natalia what do you do to relax
dance dance and dance again
it's a kind of magic
thank you thank you very much